so you're interested in playing the
hunter in destiny are you well folks
I've played the story through as a
hunter and I'm here to tell you you
can't go wrong playing as the man with
the Golden Gun
or you know the lady robot from the deep
reaches of space with the Golden Gun
but all Goldie isn't all the Hunter has
to offer there are two distinct
subclasses of hunter that differ
significantly in play style from major
differences in special abilities
grenades jumps and melee attacks to
powerful attribute tweaks and ability
modifiers there's a lot to consider when
choosing your class if you want to sign
up for the hunt it's best you know what
you're getting into let's start with the
gunslinger the first subclass of hundred
um and the one that brandishes the
burning revolver of justice super
charging yourself and whipping this bad
larry out is a great way to wipe out
three low to medium level enemies
without breaking a sweat
bing-bang-boom aim it towards a tougher
foe and you might have to spend more
than one of your precious Sun bullets
but taking a big bad out of the action
clears the field nicely for you to mop
things up with your big old hand cannon
all revolver all day the golden gun is
also helpful for boss fights and can
clean house in the crucible the only
drawback really is that you can miss
pretty easily and squander your super
fun times if your aim isn't true too bad
for you taking your time to ensure on
target shots is a must for the
gunslinger so if you're more of a
spray-and-pray kind of player you might
want to consider choosing a different
class of course it's not just the hunter
super ability that distinguishes each
subclass you'll also get different
grenade types special melee attacks and
some high-level tweaks to your jump
ability gunslingers start with
incendiary grenades which deal lingering
damage and soon unlock swarm grenades
that burst into a bunch of little
grenades and seek out enemies in general
it seems like grenades that diffuse
damage into a bunch of little
projectiles are tougher to ensure a kill
but if you follow up with some stabber E
then you're in business
the gunslinger can always melee stabbed
and when upgraded can throw a knife into
the black heart or the red eye or the
white stomach or whatever of your
enemies like with the Golden Gun aim is
paramount if you can't hit the guy it's
not worth it but when you do hit the guy
it's great you'll either kill him and
then you're all yeah eat it or you
barely do any damage and it's like you
threw your knife at a car or something
and it's hilarious take that but that's
going to scratch your paint job so
gunslinger is a very attack focused
subclass bladedancer is also a very
attacked focused subclass the difference
is range of engagement while you can sit
back and rein solar death down on
enemies as the gunslinger the Blade
Dancer gets up close and personal with
the arc blade super ability activate
this bad boy and Shazam it's dancing
time no not like dancing dancing stabby
dancing
if the reticle turns red pull the
trigger to dash forward with a deadly
strike with one upgrade the trigger will
also activate an area shockwave
this is great for clearing house in the
crucible and elsewhere mobs of enemies
will fall like wheat before the combine
like the Golden Gun it can take a few
strikes to take down bigger foes but
unlike the Golden Gun the arc blade is
pretty useless against big bosses
because getting close to them usually
means getting stomped by them close
combat always has its risks but with the
exception of those big boss enemies the
Blade Dancer can usually dance those
risks away before they become too risky
and by dance I mean stab
to further the melee madness the Blade
Dancer special melee attack is a blink
strike not the throwing knife the blink
strike teleports in a little bit letting
you stab from further away again you're
getting in close but if you level even
further both the special ability and
melee special can enable temporary
invisibility so you can get out of the
fray unharmed as for the blade dancers
grenades it's all about the flux aka
sticky grenade throw it directly at an
enemy and that enemy will die directly
the Skip grenade which fragments and
then seeks enemies might be a bit better
for mobs or four players hiding around
corners but for my money it's sticky all
the way so it really comes down to a
simple question are you a cowboy or are
you a samurai do you like the beautiful
simplicity of bang dead or do you prefer
the elegant carnage of slash slash slash
silence all of this lies in store for
the hunters of destiny and one extra
incentive the hunters double jump is
actually two successive jumps not the
weird jump and then float around in the
air styles of the Titan or the warlock
and you can upgrade it to a triple jump
or replace that second jump with a
teleport that's right it's good to be
the hunter
you